do not watch the trailer for Dreamhouse
whatever you do do not watch the trailer
for dream house dream house where's the
dream house stars Daniel Craig is the
main character Rachel Weisz is his wife
and Naomi watches his neighbor and
Daniel Craig comes home from work he's
hanging out with his wife and kids and
then you find out something is amiss in
this house that's all I can really tell
you without ruining the entire movie
like the trailer does I'm telling you
I'll tell you again do not watch the
trailer for this movie going into this
movie you're not supposed to know
everything you know from watching the
trailer the trailer spoils the movie for
you and so in the first half of this
movie there are subtleties and things
that you're not supposed to know about
the kind of subtleties that you're
supposed to notice the second time you
watch a movie but you know them because
you saw the trailer since I knew a good
solid 2/3 to 3/4 of the movie I was like
okay I know this I feel like I've seen
it before
objectively speaking if I hadn't seen
the trailer I'd be like yeah it's a nice
amount of mystery and some things going
forward it's cool figuring stuff out
about him his house the history of the
house even though there's a part of it
that seems like it's like a Frankenstein
plot like it's one plot taken from the
plot of four other movies and stitched
together I can't tell you the movies
it's taken from otherwise it'll ruin the
movie for you almost as bad as the
trailer does when you'll watch it I'm
never gonna get over that but Daniel
Craig he's a good actor he does a really
good job he's just a guy who's confused
and wants to know what the history of
his house is and why weird things are
kind of happening to him who's spying on
him from outside Rachel wise is good I
feel like she kind of disappeared off
the face of the earth I haven't seen her
and much and now she's back and I'm like
oh yeah she deserves to be in movies
she's good Naomi watches the neighbor I
mean she doesn't play a large part in
the movie but had a point in life like
Naomi Watts was climbing she was like
the chick to have in a movie at what
point does she go from that to being
like the neighbor and dream house was it
King Kong I don't know might have been
probably was I mean for the first half
of the movie there's some nice creepy
stuff going on in the movie or like
alright yeah that's the for some odd
reason for me nothing's creepier than
looking out a window at night and seeing
trees and so I don't know why it just
feels like someone's watching you and
this movie does a really good job at
playing off of that then the second half
of the movie is more like a mystery it's
no longer like oh people are watching us
from the windows something's haunted in
the house or whatever vibe they were
going for but then in the end the movie
just kind of ends it wraps up and even
then the end kind of seems confused not
confusing no confused like it didn't
know what it wanted to be like oh does
it want to be like the first
for the movie or the second half of the
movie and after all this stuff comes to
a head it gets a bit convoluted and
you're like all right now it's just
throwing stuff at us and then the movie
ends it's done it's like all yeah thanks
for coming out here your end credits now
go it's Graham I was like alright I
guess this is where I leave in the end
it's a ride but you're not gonna
remember it in T - you already saw the
trailer so what's the point
alright so Halloween's coming up we got
some monster movies we got some creepy
movies we got some scary movies we've
got some ghost movies we got paranormal
three what are you looking forward to
this Halloween comment below let me know
and yes if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more